architecture is a profession with many
rules some written some not some
relevant and others not an architect's
will constantly gravitating between
following all of these rules by the book
or making a space for imagination for
experimentation and this is a difficult
balance especially if through
architecture you're trying to challenge
preconceptions and push boundaries and
innovate even if just using what we have
around and we all the time overlooked
and this is what I've been doing along
my team in some the studio and from our
very early works that happened in strict
historic contexts like the city of
Santiago de Compostela here we built the
general Society of authors and editors a
cultural building and on top of all the
regulations we had to use stone by code
and our experience was limited but we
had incredible references to learn from
some coming from the city itself or from
nearby landscapes or other remote places
that had impacted our education as
architects and maybe you recognize here
but somehow the finished products that
industry made available for us as
architects to use in our buildings seem
to have lost their soul and so we
decided to go to the nearby quarries to
better understand the process that
transforms a mountain into a perfectly
square tile that you buy from a supplier
and we were taken by the monumental
scale of the material and the actions to
extract it and looking carefully we
noticed hundreds of irregular blocks
piling up everywhere they are the
leftovers of an extraction sequence the
ugly parts that nobody wants but we
wanted them we were inspired and it was
a win-win situation where we could get
this residual material of great
quality deemed to be crushed at a very
low cost now we had to convince our
client that this was a good idea but
foremost we had to come up with a design
process to reuse these randomly shaped
rocks and we had not done this before
and today everything would be much
easier because we would go to the quarry
with us or smartphones equipped with 3d
scans and we would document each Rock
turn that into a digital model highly
engineered the whole process but more
than a decade ago we had to embrace
uncertainty and put on our boots roll up
our sleeves and move to the quarry for a
hands-on experience and we also had to
become the contractors because we failed
at finding somebody willing to share the
risk with us now luckily we convinced
the quarry team to help us build a few
prototypes to resolve some of the
technical details and we agreed on a few
mock-ups but we got excited and one
stone led to another until we succeeded
to build an 18 meter long by 8 meter
high structure that recycled all the
amorphous material of the quarry just
supported by gravity no mortar and no
ties and once built and tested moving
into the final site in the city centre
to unite it with the rest of the
building
was a piece of cake because by having
isolated uncertainty and managed risk in
the controlled environment of the quarry
we were able to complete the whole
building in time and in budget even if
using non-conventional means and methods
and I still get goosebumps when I see
this big chunk of the industrial
landscape in the city in a building
experienced by the visitors and the
neighbors and this building gave us
quite a few headaches and so it could
have well been an exception in her work
but instead it started to inform a modus
operandi where every project becomes
this opportunity to
as the limits of a discipline we believe
has to be urgently reimagined so what
you see here are four homes that we have
designed built and inhabited for
manifestos where we are using the small
scale to ask ourselves big questions and
we are trying to discover the
architectures that result from
unconventional applications of pretty
mundane materials and technologies like
concrete in different forms in the top
row or steel and foam in the bottom row
take for instance these precast concrete
beams you've probably seen them building
bridges highways water channels we found
them in one of our visits to a precast
concrete factory and they might not seem
especially homey or beautiful but we
decided to use them to build our first
house and this was an incredible moment
because we got to be architects as
always builders once more and for the
first time we could be your own clients
so here we are trying to figure out how
we can take this huge catalog beams of
about 20 tons each and stack them
progressively around a quarter space the
heart of the house and due to their
dimensions and their material quality
these big parts are the structure that
carry the loads to the ground but they
are much more than that
they are the swimming pool they are the
walls that divide interior from exterior
they are the windows that frame the
views they're the finishes they're the
very spirit of this house a house that
is for us a laboratory where we are
testing how we can use standard elements
in non-standard ways and we are
observing that the results are
intriguing and we are learning by doing
that prefabrication can be much more
than stacking boxes or that heavy parts
can be airy and transparent
and on top of designing and building
this house we're getting valuable
feedback sharing it with our family and
our friends because this is our life and
our working progress
the lessons that we learn here get
translated into other projects and other
programs and other skills as well and
they inspire new work here again we are
looking at very standard products
galvanized steel stats that can be
easily cut and screwed insulating foams
cement boards all materials that you can
find hidden in partition walls and that
we are exposing and we are using them to
build a very lightweight construction
system that can be built almost by
anyone and we are doing it ourselves
with our hands in our shop and we are
architects we're not professional
builders but we want to make sure it's
possible and it's so lives that Anton
can move it with his hands and Xavier
can put it in a container and we can
ship it like you would ship your
belongings if you were moving abroad
which is what we did five years ago we
moved her gravity center from Madrid and
the house of the concrete beams to
Brooklyn and we found the ugly duckling
of a very nice neighborhood
a one-story garage and the only thing we
could afford but it was okay because we
wanted to transform it into a swan
installing on top or just delivered kit
of parts once more becoming the
scientists and the guinea pigs so this
is a house that uses some of the
cheapest and most normal materials that
you can find in the market that applies
the ubiquitous 4 by 8 modulation that
governs construction industry and yet a
different organization of the spaces and
a different assembly of the parts is
able to transform an economically built
home into luxurious space and now we're
dreaming and we are actively working
with developers with builders with
communities to try to make this
reality for many more homes and many
more families and you see the world
around us it's an infinite source of
inspiration if we are curious enough to
see beneath the surface of things now
I'm going to take you to the other side
of the Moon to the sublime landscape of
Montana where a few years ago we joined
Cathy and Peter Halsted to imagine
tippet Rice Art Center on a ten thousand
acre working ranch and when we first
visited the site we realized that all we
knew about what an Art Center is was
absolutely pointless for that clients
for that community for that landscape
the kind of white box museum type had no
feet here so we decided to explode the
center into a constellation of fragments
of a spaces it spread across the vast
territory that would immerse the
visitors into the wilderness of this
amazing place so back in the office we
are thinking through making using the
land both as support and as material
learning from its geological processes
of sedimentation erosion fragmentation
crystallization explosion to discover
architectures that are worn from the
land
there are visceral extensions of the
landscape like this bridge that crosses
Murphy Canyon or this fountain like
these space stopping a hill or the
sphere that brings to us the space of
the mountains and its sound and in order
to realize this idea construction cannot
be perfectly plans we need to embrace
the drastic weather and the local craft
we need to control just those aspects
that are critical like the structural
the thermal via crystal properties and
better in the form but otherwise
improvisation is welcome and is provoked
and a moment of construction is a still
a moment of design and a moment of
celebration where different hands hearts
minds come together to
for a final dance and the result then
cannot be anticipated it comes as a
surprise and we unwrap architecture that
you wouldn't wrap a birthday gift
architecture is uncovered it's
discovered it's extracted from the guts
of the earth to build a shelter one of
the most basic human needs architecture
art landscape archaeology geology all
made one and by using the resources at
or disposal in radical ways by making a
space for experimentation we are able to
bring to light architectures that find
the beauty latent in the raw and
imperfect things that surround us let's
elevate them and let them speak their
own language thank you
[Applause]